you
i
All right friends it is ten o'clock in this session of the with this work
session of the council is convened all council members are present and the
purpose of our meeting today we have one agenda item and that is to solicit
input from council members
solicit input from council members regarding their thoughts on the budget
so we will just go ahead and who wants to kick it off David okay go for it
David what are your thoughts on the budget do you have any input you would
like to share with finance department yeah I'm just curious how we failing
going towards the end of the fiscal year even flush underwater I want I want to
buy four helicopters for our police department financial outlook in general
for the 26th budget as far as where we are but the actuals we are we are on we
are we are in it we are fine as far as the financial aid is concerned we are on
budget but we are not you know way ahead of budget obviously revenue got got
reduced at the last mid-year when we did the mid-year visions I have not done any
forecasting for the revenue to finish out you know for the 27 I was waiting
until we kind of got through a few one more month to get there but but we will
we will be working on that soon but in general I would say you know we're okay
but we're not seeing any revenue any large revenue growth okay that's
sufficient thank you miss miss miss while we have you there go ahead and finish oh
yeah well I was just gonna talk about my few items on the wish list is that let
me let me ask them so well you mentioned the mid-year budget correction and that
was because of a shortfall in our sales tax that largely no that was largely due
to the pilot reduction so so we had it got offset by property taxes increasing
so so that it helped that time we are still working on the pilots with with
Huntsville utilities but and working through the the questions and the
reasons and what's behind that but but yes you know in general it's still you
know it all kinds of kind of tends to go back to that even you know we're kind of
even across the board okay thank you all right mr. little continue your thoughts
my my thoughts are pretty general quality of life focused it may be Shane
can answer this question the California Street Park I know has been on a list
for a while to get facelift maybe some pickleball courts but it's my
understanding that there's some shared property with the school over there so
it's not real clear yet what we can do so I just would like to know that that's
still on somebody's radar for one of the new schools in and everything that we
might be able to because I get asked about California Street Park I'm sure
mr. clean does too because it's right you know right across the street from me
just want to make sure that's still you know something in the works might be a
few years but yeah so you know in in our help with the tip that you approved
last night there's some funding to help the schools with New Huntsville Middle
and through that conversation we've been having conversations with the school
system of once we get the school built under construction working with them
with a master plan for California Park and how it would benefit the public and
what the program would be so I think next year and a half that they've just
bid the school they're getting ready to break ground you know I think once they
get a year into that and John Hamilton has been intimately involved with that
I think you'll see some visioning sessions of what that that will become
but it's definitely in the in the future forecast for making improvements to that
part okay that's great yes sir turn on your mic yeah mr. clean different times
when I am over in the park just every time I'm there I've noticed that people
are actually using the tennis courts to play pickleball on so there's some
improvisation taking place I think that definitely would be a good place and
your folks landscape management somebody on a frequent basis I've noticed people
over there trimming cutting the grass trimming the branches and everything so
we'd like to see new things like mr. little said but at this point it has not
been neglected it's still being well-maintained that's correct yeah it's
still public park and we maintain all our parts we should be in landscape
management's annual monthly maintenance so but but yes they're there good things
coming in the future for that part for sure alrighty and then the other
something else I wanted to mention was the walking path around the pond down at
Jones Valley Park like by Linden yeah and in the greenway apparently about a
portion of it is paved and a portion of it is gravel and so as my understanding
I might just be more of a budgetary issue to get the whole thing paved I
don't know shouldn't be I'd like to see if that's a possibility down the road
there's a there's some older neighbors that live there that I've heard from so
you know about half their walks pretty straightforward and the rest on a
uneven pavement and I've talked to Chris and they'll get out and smooth the
gravel and make it better but if it's possible to pave that entire walking
path I'd take care of that today with engineering it shouldn't be something we
have to go put in the budget I know the commercial there along Colty Jones
there was an extension of that greenway to get up to the sidewalk area it may be
that area I know there were some delineation of some city works and
private developer work there and then you've had the development on four mile
post we put in the new bridge to get you know to that area just let me get
engineering to go look at that but they would be funds through our greenway
maintenance to get that taken care of now okay great yeah thank you all that
the folks I heard from recently yeah we can take care of that pretty easily thank
you the rest madam president is just make sure our public safety stays fully
funded and road budget stays fully funded so pretty you know straightforward
thanks mr. Davis and thank you madam president thank you miss Watkins we'll
just finish up on this side yes so as we're moving forward in this budget
process the things that I want are things that will enhance improve the
life of the residents in district one so I'm requesting funding consideration for
the refurbishment and re of the revitalization of Cary Hills, Stonerfield
and Lakewood these parks have served our community for several generations and
throughout the generations they've declined a little bit so I would like to
see those athletic fields upgraded improving the field houses and creating
a fresh and warm welcoming environment that reflects the pride and values of
our neighborhoods. Cabra Hills, Lakewood and Stonerfield and I'll make this
comment about Stonerfield I wish James Gossett was here I think Lakewood has
been on the decline with the fields and the field house so if that is the case
and now they're more so over at the shower center which will you know get a
facelift then we can take that off the list I don't have a problem with that
but I do know that Stonerfield and Cabra Hills definitely needs upgrade thank you
Is that it Ms. Watkins? Very good. I thought I was gonna come here with a long list didn't you?
I thought that was number one. Very good Mr. Kling. Well I would like to
stand in support with Councilmember Watkins on the northern bypass I think
that's a great arterial I know it's getting underway anyway that can be a
accelerated the sooner that is done the better and then I'm standing with my
good friend Mr. Little when we start looking at expanding over toward Hampton
Cove from 72 East the eastern bypass and coming around and then I'm best buddies
with Councilmember Council President Robinson on the East Arsenal connector
the ring road around the city I think is very important for people of my district
because this all the stop-and-go traffic that creates congestion but I think it's
good for the city I know we have a plan for those if there's any windfall that
comes from the state or the federal government those would be the projects
I would like to see accelerated and of course the Parkway at 565 interchange
very important again we're talking about traffic flow for the city which is good
for the district and also good for everybody else's district on a park
basis there are just a couple of parks where trying to get grass seed to grow
we had to go a couple of times around to get Hastings Park and the grass
grass grew and it's doing very well Archer Park and West Lawn parks both
have large bare dirt areas and again whatever can be done whether it's sod or
whether it's a good durable grass seed in fact grass seed is what worked at
Hastings Park but just make a concentrated effort to to see what can
be done within those neighborhood parks also there's been great progress and if
there's a way we can continue to accelerate residential street sweeping
if landscape management the administration feels that more
equipment's needed I think that would certainly be money well spent
Triana Boulevard we are seeing a lot of interest in having a crosswalk put at
fantasy Playhouse possibly that may actually happen in this fiscal year if
not given the amount of young children in traffic that would certainly be a
very worthwhile project to have place in the upcoming fiscal year budget
everybody on the council I think would agree the council directed projects
process has been working well everyone brings their ideas to the table they're
reaffirmed by everybody on the council and I think there's a lot of mutual
respect out of the ideas that the individual council member brings for his
or her district so I would certainly like to see that continue I would echo
what I think Councilman Little said we want to make sure our police and fire
manpower are what they need to be as well as community development inspectors
as we're growing outward we're you know may have certain needs that need to be
expanding the fire department ISO ranking is very good despite our large
land area so that's credit to them police department crime statistics are
very good according to the FBI for a city our size and if you think of
Birmingham is having a lesser population than we have their crime statistics are
very very poor so I appreciate the good job that's done by those departments and
I guess in a way I'm saying I want to support and do whatever is needed I know
from time to time we've had people talk to us about the Huntsville library
situation downtown looking around and what I found out it's not really put out
or people don't really talk that much about it but there's a new library that
the city helped put in North Huntsville there's a new library the city
participated in for South Huntsville the library downtown certainly could use
something done to it I think it's poor management on their part that we have
things like water fountains that aren't working and I know we had employees
talking about their salary levels I don't know all the ins and outs of that I
do know that historically we have provided the library with the largest
appropriation that we've made to any outside agency I guess bottom line is
that I haven't heard anything from the library and I think we need to hear from
the library and the board as far as what what they're planning or what their
preferences are I mean I don't know if they want to renovate the existing
building do they want to build a new library building at that same location
do they want to build a new library building at a different location and what
is going to happen to keep the library operating while construction is going on
whether it's a new library or whether it's just renovation within the the
existing library so bottom line is I think we just need to be kind of
receptive to them but instead of us trying to ram something down their throat
we need to find out what what the director and what the library board want
to do and you know we could certainly look at at being supportive and in
helping them one other thing road resurfacing I think we all like road
resurfacing I love road resurfacing I think there needs to be better
management between the resurfacing and the contract and the concrete that's
put down in the district I represent I think I've heard from other districts
too there's a long waiting period where streets are torn up they're milled the
concrete curving that needs to be put in is put in new sidewalk new aprons are
put in some cases even sidewalks and while we're doing that and that's
finally getting done then there are in some cases months of waiting where the
streets are especially torn up and people are waiting for the asphalt to
come in and so I think in the future that needs to be better managed and also
I think we need to ride herd on these contractors a little bit better myself
and I think I know at least one other council member are still waiting on FY
25 road projects to be complete and you know we pay the people in the
neighborhoods are having a little bit of an extra rough time because they're
they're driving around a torn up street that's been milled and they're waiting
for the asphalt to come so maybe we could work that a little bit better but
certainly let's let's keep the resurfacing at the highest levels
possible and if there's any money left I'll yield to the floor and let the let
somebody else try to spend the rest of it but there's a lot of good things
going on with our department heads and I think we certainly this is time just to
say thanks to them for the great job that they do every year thank you mr.
cling mr. Meredith thank you there's a lot going on right now in district 5
and the largest most solid foundation for that activity is the financial
commitment of this administration and I want to acknowledge that I I know
sometimes folks think I don't get along with our mayor but I do I like him I
support him I think his his vision for the city is a good one having the
luxury of being a ground floor participant in the city's updated
master plan for the West I am confident that the city will continue to
financially support district 5 to the fullest in fiscal year 27
consequently my ass for the districts are simple and minimalistic first and
foremost is something that comes up pretty much every time we get to this
point in our our fiscal year is sidewalks and sidewalks on Balch Road
sidewalks on old railroad bed and now sidewalks on Zert Road south of from
Martin Road to Baron Fork Road specifically to facilitate the patronage
to the new rec center there at Martin insert the other things I'm going to
mention specific to district 5 or things that are probably already being
accounted for in the administration but because of the topic of this work
session I'm going to mention them and that is the pavilion in the fanning
reserve preserve rather on old Jim Williams Road I think that that is
something that mr. Hamilton is working in conjunction with the Madison County
Commission specifically Commissioner Haraway the monument signed for the rec
center the West Huntsville rec center it's a little bit confusing to those
that aren't regulars there how to get in because it looks like the driveway is in
front of the building when in fact it is several meters away and there are folks
that try to make a premature left that frankly can be putting themselves in
danger of being hit by some pretty fast moving traffic on Martin Road the next
is the dog park down by what used to be Cabela's I guess it's a bass Pro Shop
now and of course the infamous second entrance for the west side of Providence
there's been a lot of talk about parks so I'll jump in on that and the creation
of some additional parks out west would be very welcome and I would say we don't
need water features let's keep it economical and just have grass and shade
we don't need water features that run up the price and frankly keep the
maintenance cost up as well the other things are a little bit more universal
and I would like to see additional monies allocated to the Children's
Advocacy Center and the work that they do and then finally full staffing for
ladder trucks and hazmat units tentatively in discussions the price
point for that would be a hundred ninety two thousand dollars which is not cheap
but is something that is definitely needed at least well it's definitely
needed everywhere but when you have outlying stations that are traveling
quite a ways to respond having a full ladder truck to allow them to do their
primary mission which is actually going into buildings and looking for people
and saving lives as opposed to standing outside and fighting the fire would be
helpful and that is all I have madam president thank you mr. Meredith so I
would like to just revisit a couple of things one is library we've had people
coming and talking particularly about raises for library mayor battle do you
we don't pay salaries for the library I think our allocation is capital books we
also provides it's just a it's everything but direct allocation and
the library board along with administration of the library determines
on how they're going to spend their money okay and I think I have also
understood that the library employees are that's a county some reason I have
thought they were they work work with the county on that but in any way we do
an allocation and again it comes back the library board for salaries and then
as mr. cling also alluded to earlier decisions regarding the building how it
will be rebuilt where it will be rebuilt that is a library concern miss Smith
I'm just real quick if I can just clarify and I believe what you've already said
all of the buildings for libraries are owned and by the city of Huntsville we
the operations of what happens inside the library is turned over to the boards
our library system is a is a fully Madison County and so so they operate
both within the city they operate libraries in the city of Madison in the
county and in the city of Huntsville and so that is their responsibility kind of
wide and and so but all of their funding for what happens in the city of
Huntsville they segregate their libraries and the way that they operate
and their operational cost and so we pay for all of that they do get some
funding from the state they do get funding from the county and then
obviously the ones that are operated in the city of Madison are that that is
fully separate from what we do as well so again just to make make it clear we
have heard the request for increase in salaries but that is a library board
decision and we continue to make our allocation and I believe our allocation
to the library is one of the largest we make to any outside agency it is a large
allocation and and and and so we can we can put forth to y'all kind of what we
have allocated to them over the past few years thank you and we certainly value
the library it is a city service and so I don't have a problem at all with us
making that large allocation but again everything is under the control of the
of the library board and then echo also what mr. little said regarding public
safety both police and fire I know we are continuing to have challenges
filling positions but so both police and fire are fully funded as I understand
with staffing we just need to recruit and get people into those positions is
that correct and Green Mountain firetruck thank you very much for the
fleet is going to be between the private donations from the Green Mountain folks
and the city allocations from from fleet we're going to get that firetruck up
there on Green Mountain and support that paving has I don't know in the last 10
years I think it has doubled but we are probably have reached capacity because
it sounds like we're having a hard time I think from the 2025 last paving we're
having trouble catching up with those but the bid process has changed a little
bit to make other bidders or other contractors come in and kind of fill
that void is that right Shane so if we can just continue to fund it and then
make sure that the work gets done that's the I think that's the challenge that
mr. little mentioned earlier we also have built a lot of new parks we have a
lot of new areas to maintain I want to make sure that parks and
landscape both have the funding they need to maintain what we have because
it's great to have the parks but if they're not cut and landscaped
appropriately it's not a good reflection on the city and they have been
beautifully done I'm just I just want to make sure we haven't outrun our
headlights on that one so funding for parks and landscape to maintain the
parks we have would be wonderful the 565 interchange we have very little
that's not about funding with us that's that's finding funding from state and
federal and I know we are working on that but that becomes more and more
crucial every day the star snow connector will help take some of the
load off of 565 and I'm encouraged to see we've started that first piece of it
again that's mostly LDOT money that we're using there so we need to consider
that and I actually joined mr. cling on his comments about street sweepers I
have seen street sweepers now it used to be we just did the main
connector roads now they're in the residential streets regularly and it has
made a significant difference so I'm grateful that we have those new street
sweepers and that they are being used regularly so really my my thoughts are
just can we keep on keeping on and make and just continue to do the good work
make sure public safety has the funds that they need both for personnel and
for fleet and capital looking forward to the south precinct the new south
precinct on the parkway we've acquired the land and at some point that will be
in the capital plan and we'd like to see that move forward both for them and for
the neighborhood and that's all I have anybody else have any other comments miss
I do when you mentioned street sweepers it triggers some for me I do want to see
if we can get a street sweeper more often in district one because all of the
traffic that comes from the two quarries and the asphalt we constantly have rocks
on the ground at the intersection of stringfield and pelaski and stringfield
I mean winchester and pelaski and maston lake and pelaski and it's every day I bet
it creates a mess it does and then I was told that those rocks sometime can get
embedded in the road and that's what causes your potholes and we just got those streets
paved so I want to make sure that we're able to maintain them but we definitely need the
street sweeper in district one I do want to give kudos to Vulcan because they street sweep every
day but the problem is they don't come down on that end and it's some of it's not their
responsibility because they have two contractors on their property so we just want to try to keep
those roads upgrading and up to date as well as I'm hopeful that we can get fire stations
in the budget as well it's a couple of fire stations in the city that really need to be replaced
thank you any other thoughts Mr. Mayor I'll chime in district five sees
I've never seen a street sweeper in district five anywhere and frankly if we can get a park you can
keep the street sweeper okay very good any other thoughts well if we have Mayor Battle do you want
to chime in any thoughts you know I want to thank the council for taking the time out to go through
these items and these these are great items many of them are already you know already in the budget
many of them are going to be items that that we'll be working on we have had several groups come to us
for capital needs and very significant capital needs which have to work within the 10-year capital
plan and you know I think everybody needs to recognize that if they come to us with a plan
right now whether it's for the library or whether it's for early works or whether it's for
you know the land trust or whoever you know it's got to work within a capital plan and usually it
starts off in year 10 and slowly but surely it comes to come to fruition because it gives us time
to to stagger our payments and make sure that you know we we do it within a budgetary responsible
way so you know with the capital plans are are being pushed you'll I think each of you all
probably have some meetings or have had some meetings with some different groups
uh and um that's that's something that we'll have to fit into the capital plans a lot of this is
is products that are already in works or um are we're working for and you know we want to thank
you for you know reiterating these to make sure that we're on the right track and um we'll we'll
continue to work with you and hopefully the budget will reflect what you need out of these
we we really appreciate the very collaborative nature of the relationship between the
administration and the council that is unique uh for a lot of municipalities and
we thank you for the good working relationship you and your team have with us
so unless anybody has any other council any other comments oh miss miss smith real quick
I know most of you brought a list if you could make a copy of that and send that to us that would
be great I've made a lot of notes I know we have others that are making notes as well
but if we have it directly from y'all then then we can make sure that our notes are correct
and while we have you there can you just review for us the September schedule for the budget
presentations so I don't have the dates off the top of my head but we will introduce the
budget at the first September meeting and then there will be a work September 10 so September
10th and then we will be a work session in between if I can interject isn't that going to be a
special session and not a work session the special session is on September 16th
I'm sorry 18th September 18th which is in between the dropping up and then Friday that's on that
Friday and then and then the the budget would be approved on the 24th correct okay any other
questions and thoughts we are adjourned thank you all for your input
you